this is a production of Cornell
University so I'm gonna tell you a
journey that I feel is a little bit of a
two-fold journey because it's partially
a journey of me and my research and how
it progressed but I'm also gonna be
talking about the journey that sugar
takes through a plant because I'm gonna
be talking about phloem transport so I
started my scientific career more in the
field of ecology and even my graduate
research was asking ecological questions
and trying to think about the different
physiological factors the different
aspects of plant stress tolerance that
influence where species occur across the
landscape so very sort of basic
questions in terms of ecology and when I
was doing a lot of this work I kept
finding what I felt was a familiar theme
when you look at all the things that
influence the way that plants interact
with the environment a lot of it has to
do with resource allocation are they
investing in really stress tolerant
structures do they have very dense wood
that can deal with drought conditions
how are they changing their growth rate
at different times of the year I was
doing work on wetland plants and root
elongation was really important in
determining where they were occurring
and how fast they could establish at
different sites and there's a lot of
different aspects of carbon allocation
or other kinds of nutrient allocation
that impact the way that plants interact
with other organisms and the way they
interact with each other and so through
all this work it made me start thinking
about well what is happening in terms of
this allocation and specifically in
terms of the carbon and I started
thinking about how carbon is moved
around the plants what do we know about
this and how does it affect these larger
processes
and so I got interested in studying the
phloem and so this may all be reviewed
to you but I figured I'd take a moment
and talk to you about how the phloem
functions so the phloem is the part of
the vascular system that transports
sugar and it operates in a very specific
mechanism it's very directional on one
hand you have an area that's providing
the sugar this is your source tissue it
we often think of this as being the lead
because it's where photosynthesis is
happening but it can also be coming out
of storage and in that source tissue you
have the loading of a lot of sugars
happening into the phloem and this is
really important because it causes the
phloem to have a high pressure you're
gonna have a whole bunch of water move
in after you have the loading of the
sugar this pressure is important because
it's part of what drives phloem
transport so other parts of the plant
any place that's having active growth
this could be your roots this could be
fruit this could be an apical meristem
that's growing you're having a similar
but opposite phenomenon happening the
plants removing sugar from the system
and so in this part of the plant you're
pulling out the sugar and you're
reducing the pressure and so the plant
causes this pressurized this pressure
gradient that drives this circulation
from the source to the sink and this is
the way that we think transport happens
in the phloem now similar to the diagram
that I've shown here you often will see
pictures of the phloem that look like
this they look like a large pipe an
empty tube with these plates in between
the cells but this is very stylized and
I always like to show a picture of what
the actual tissue looks like so this is
a scanning electron micrograph of a cell
in the phloem
and the reason I like this picture is
because it reminds us that this is a
living tissue we're not talking about
pipes I'm gonna talk to you a little bit
about models that you'd use and Flaum
transport how we think about it being
how we think about carbon moving in the
phloem but we have a system here of
interconnected living cells they have
fewer organelles than a lot of the
neighbor neighboring cells but they do
have organelles and most importantly I
would say they have a membrane and so
this is something that's really
important not just for how the phloem
functions but it's also really important
in explaining why we don't know much
about the phloem
so we have a system that is pressurized
that's surrounded by a membrane so that
means if you manipulate it if you cut it
you can influence not only how it
functions but where everything is inside
of it and so for a long time there's
been a lot of debates about what even
the phloem looks like in an intact
system and so one thing I'm really
interested in is trying to understand
the connection this basic connection
between structure and function it's it's
sort of a you know the baseline when you
get into physiology but it's something
we don't really understand that well in
the phone so you can think about this in
a lot of different levels you know
plants have complex three-dimensional
architecture and different branching
patterns this we can imagine how this
would impact where carbon can move how
it can move and growth patterns but we
don't understand the connections that
lie there you can think about on a
tissue level there's a lot of variation
in what florrum looks like and how much
different plants have and where it's
located and we do not have a good idea
of what that means in terms of plant
growth reproduction or even just
patterns of carbon movement in the plant
and when you get down to this cellular
level so here you know we're looking at
those tubes with the individual cells
that are separated by plates there's a
large amount of variation among species
and what the cells look like they vary
in what the plates look like they vary
in how large the tubes are and we don't
understand the implications of this
we're just starting to scratch the
surface on some of these pretty basic
questions in trying to understand it
understand the design of the phloem why
why does it work so well and what are
the implications of it and so what I
want to talk to you about today is three
different projects that I've worked on
that are trying to get at this this
connection between structure and
function and I've organized this in
terms of three different questions so
I've been curious thinking about how
does phloem physiology and Anatomy
impact how much carbon can be moved in a
plant how far it can be moved and when
it can be moved and so I'm gonna start
with the very seasoned the appropriate
first one which is work on pumpkins
right so it's almost Halloween so I had
to talk about pumpkins and I got
interested in this because I was curious
what happens when you have a plant
that's allocating a lot of Carman really
rapidly to on developing structure and
so so look at this I didn't look at just
any pumpkin I figured I wanted to find
the biggest pumpkins so I did my work on
giant pumpkins and I had the pleasure of
working with the New England giant
pumpkin growers and these are many of
the growers that I worked with I also
did this work in collaboration with
Missy Holbrook and Dustin Haines and so
I started thinking about these giant
pumpkins and trying to understand and
figure out how they're able to move so
much carbon into this developing
structure
so what I did is I decided to compare
different types or different varieties
of this species so giant pumpkins are
all in the species cucurbit of Maxima
you might know this species from Hubbard
squash there's a lot of squashes that
have the same species they're just
different variety so this giant pumpkin
is not related to the field pumpkin that
you typically know but it's been under
very strong selection for over the last
century for size because people have
been competitively growing pumpkins in
this country since the early 1900s and
gradually over time we've seen an
increase in the size of these pumpkins
one of the big breakthroughs was in the
1970s we had the development of the
Atlantic giant variety this is the
variety that is used in almost all of
the giant pumpkin competitions nowadays
and I I'm not sure it could be that this
very moment this records being broken it
gets broken very quickly so it's hard to
keep it up to date and it's the time of
season but the world record is somewhere
around 2600 pounds so these can grow
very large all right so to understand
what's happening with giant pumpkins I
decided I wanted to look at several
varieties urban and maxima and look at
their phloem from source to sink so
thinking about their leaves all the way
to the fruit and I picked two giant
varieties so the Atlantic giant or the
competitive ones there are mammoth ones
which are another smaller but also giant
pumpkin variety and the Hubbard squash
so these are all the same species but
they invest different amounts in their
fruit and I grew all of these in a
greenhouse so most of the work I'm going
to talk to you about is green house work
but then I was also able to work with
the giant pumpkin growers and get data
from field ground giant pumpkins to add
to it and I'll talk to you a little bit
about what I found in that so the first
thing I started doing was looking at
some of the basics
is there a difference in how much they
photosynthesize there isn't so on a
source level in terms of carbon being
fixed it's similar among all the
varieties I looked at some aspects of
the fruit especially the young ovaries
and despite the fact that the Hubbard
squash had a slightly different shape
and color actually remarkably similar
the cell sizes in the tissues are the
same the same water content in carbon
content same mass very similar early
trajectory of their growth I also wanted
to look at how much carbon is being
moved in the phloem and I looked at this
in the leaves so I've done some work on
who turbines in the past where I have
measured phloem transport using a
fluorescent dye that we can get into the
phloem and by doing this and using
really sensitive light sensors can
actually detect movement in an intact
plant so you actually don't have to cut
into the plant or disturb anything and
so I was able to do this on the leaves
of these different pumpkin species and
the same as when I looked at
photosynthesis when you look at the
amount of carbon so this is the
volumetric transport in these three
different varieties out of the leaves
the exporting the same amount of carbon
all right so there's not a difference
here you're starting to notice a pattern
I looked at the cells there's also not a
difference there so you look at the
cells and the phloem you look at these
are the plates that separate the cells
same size same pore size the transport
cells are same in all the varieties
right yes yes so it's one species and
all these varieties so huge difference
in what's happening with the growth of
the fruit at the end but a lot of
similarities right so what's what's
going on here well I did find one
distinct difference that was really
strong between these varieties and it
had to do with the amount of flow that
they had so when you looked at a
cellular level the cells were the same
but they had more of them so this is the
cross sectional area of the flow um I
have it here in the pedestal I also
looked at it in the stem and the petiole
these patterns are true really
throughout the whole plant when you look
at the two giant varieties they have
about three percent more phloem than the
non giant variety and the field grown
ones have even higher now I can't
differentiate between whether this is a
genetic effect of it being more of an
award-winning genotype or whether it's
driven by the environmental effects of
being grown in a field but these three
varieties were all grown in the same
conditions so what this looks like is
happening is there has been a big shift
in the giant pumpkins from other
varieties Cucurbita Maxima in the amount
of film that they actually have inside
of their tissue now in addition to that
there are some interesting differences
that are in the way the phloem is
structured and I always put this out
when I talk about this maybe somebody
here knows more about this and I do I
just find it a little bit odd
I always think acute carbons is having
very consistent vascular structure these
giant varieties even when their fruits
are at a young age start having some
irregularities so you would often see
vascular bundles appearing in the middle
of the cortex which could create these
strings in the center of the stem and
the pumpkin or you start having really
weird vascular and your regular basket
arrangement so it's it's a little bit of
an interesting pattern and along in
addition to having more phloem the way
it's arranged starts changing especially
as they get bigger so I was curious to
try to understand this shift this 3%
shift in the amount of phloem does it
actually matter does it make a
difference
to get at this I actually worked with
the pumpkin growers to model carbon
transport into the pumpkins and so the
pumpkin growers are really careful at
grow measuring the dimensions of their
pumpkins often daily sometimes it's more
weekly and they've got very detailed
charts about how weight relates to size
and so you can look at these growth
trajectories for all of these pumpkins
and I was also able to get samples from
some of the field grown plants to get an
idea of how much water and carbon and
how much phloem there was in the plants
at each of their stages during
development and so it's pretty amazing
when you start getting into this we know
these are large pumpkins not surprising
when you start looking at the date and
you realize they can grow 20 kilograms a
day it's a little bit mind-boggling at
least to me in terms of carbon that's
could be somewhere around 600 grams of
carbon can be moving into the pumpkin in
one day and so I use the data that I had
to actually look at transport velocity I
was curious how fast does carbon moving
into these pumpkins and that's what
we're seeing here this is transport
velocity with mass and I'm you know we
could we could talk for a while about
the trends and if there's a trend and
I'm not going to go into that what I
want to draw attention to is some of the
numbers that we're looking at which may
not have meaning to you unless you've
actually measured a lot of phloem
transport the thing to note is that in
any literature I found on cue turbines
so going beyond pumpkins talking about
cucumbers they all have a foam transport
velocity that tends to average somewhere
in this range it's really common they're
around point one to point one and that's
where this falls out and what's
interesting is if you go into this model
and you ask the question what happens if
we decrease the cross-sectional area of
phloem so that it's more like the
Hubbard squash you would have to have
velocities that are normal
three times larger and these are larger
than anything we've ever measured in a
cubit now they're not beyond the range
that we've seen in other plants but this
makes you think it makes me think right
about what's going on here and so you
know getting to this question with giant
pumpkins it seems like what's happening
is these pumpkins are able to move a lot
of carbon into that developing fruit
because they have more phloem if you
want to think about this in terms of a
simple equation
you've got the area of the phloem the
transport velocity and that's going to
determine that volumetric flow rate and
so they are increasing the area but the
velocity seems to be saying similar into
the fruit and to me this is interesting
because it creates another question
right so this is what makes the most
exciting research I think is when you're
left with a bigger question and so what
I see when I look at this is a question
about transport capacity why is it that
cue cards don't just increase the flow
through those tubes is there a limit to
how fast they can move carbon with their
Anatomy and that's something we don't
know
but the fact that the strategy that we
see here for increasing flow rate into a
pumpkin
results from more tissue instead of
increased capacity of transport in those
tissue to me makes me wonder about what
is actually happening and how does cue
kerbin Anatomy influence bone transport
velocity so that's a question that I'm
hoping to look at more in the future all
right so now for something very
different completely I like to jump
around systems so maybe there's a little
bit for everyone I'm hoping we're gonna
go from talking about pumpkins and a
more of an agricultural system to
talking about trees and vines
so there's been a lot of ongoing debate
and discussion about how plants are able
to move carbon really long distances you
know some tree is king and 100 meters
tall it's a long distance to move from
the canopy to the roots and this is
especially a challenging thing to think
about when you're thinking about the
mechanism that I explained right we're
having a situation where just these
local osmotic gradients are creating a
pressure that's driving passively carbon
movement the whole length of the plant
and as you increase the length of that
pathway you should be increasing the
resistance this is basics of fluid flow
through a pipe if that's the case then
as you grow taller you wouldn't be able
to move as much and trees would have
slower and slower and slower carbon
transport and this this is a little bit
problematic to the way that we think
about growth and the way that we think
about the vascular system and so I
worked in collaboration with Missy again
and also Michael Knobloch at Washington
State to try to get at this question and
we started initially in a system that
was a little simpler than trees we
started with a Morning Glory all right
and what we wanted to do with the
Morning Glory was measure basically as
much as we could about the phloem and
see if we could get the numbers to add
up right we have this theory about how
phloem transport happens what happens if
we measure everything that goes into
those equations does it actually work
and does it change as you increase the
length of the plant and so here I've
given you just a simple equation for
flow some of you may be familiar this
some of you may not but bear with me
it's pretty straight for it so when
you're having pressure driven flow the
velocity how fast it can move is going
to be related to the pressure gradient
so this is the pressure between the
source and the sink and
whatever the resistance is in the tissue
and this is going to be influenced by
the height of the tree the viscosity of
the solution is going to be influenced
by the anatomy of the tubes and so there
was a large group of us that were in
Missy and Michael's lab at all through
everything we could at this just to give
you an idea of some of the people and
some of the stuff that was involved
we measured phloem transport velocity
using c11 we did a lot of detailed
microscopy work we collaborated with
physicists who helped us model it core
Jennsen we estimated velocity sorry
viscosity inside of sieve tubes using
molecular rotors and we used some newly
developed pressure gauges to measure
pressure in the different tissues and
what we found was really interesting
they're sort of two key things that
jumped out when we looked at this trying
to understand what's actually happening
in terms of all of these different
factors as a plant's growing taller like
are they actually slowing down their
carbon transport or not well one of the
things that we found was that that
pressure inside of the leaves increased
as the morning glories got taller so
here is a little schematic of it we
altered the the length harshly by
manipulating where the lowest leaf was
and so the longest difference between a
source and a sink on a whole handful of
plants and we measured pressure in the
phloem at those top leaves and what we
find is that as you get to be longer at
least if you're a Morning Glory the
pressure inside of the phloem and the
leaf increases so this is really cool
it's suggesting well maybe these plants
are compensating by just pressurizing
their phloem more but this wasn't the
only difference that we saw that wasn't
the only thing that happened is the
plants grew taller another thing that
happened is
anatomy changed so these are the same
plates that connect the cells in the
phloem and as you go from the top to the
bottom of one of these tall plants you
will find that those plates get more and
more complex and they have more and more
parts and the pores are bigger and the
tubes are bigger so the anatomy of the
plant is actually changing as the plants
growing and that's really important when
we're thinking about resistance of a
tooth if you ever want to make water
move faster through a tube make that
tube wider a the simplest simplest thing
you can do and so having these kinds of
structural changes we think are really
important in allowing these plants to
transport over longer distance because
it decreases that a resistance that
they're experiencing so this is really
cool and great and everything but to me
the question was well hello this morning
gorg it's still just 14 meters it's not
really as big as plants can get and it's
also this hurt it's it's an herbaceous
or herbaceous plant and we know that
there is there are differences in
species in what's happening in that
phloem loading zone and a lot of trees
appear to have a more passive loading
system in terms of how they move sugar
into the phloem and this is important
when we're thinking about this
phenomenon that we saw in the morning
glory so the morning glories show this
ability to increase the pressure in
their phloem and our best thought is
that this has to do with the fact that
they actively load sugars into their
phloem and so there is a control
mechanism there for potentially altering
the pressure in the tissue but with a
lot of trees they rely just on a
concentration gradient from the mess of
mesophyll into the phloem and this
and a system is hard to imagine it's
hard to imagine that it could pressurize
easily may you know maybe it can
but our suspicion was is that that they
weren't doing the same thing as the
morning glories and so I led a project
to look specifically at trees we looked
at nine different species to try to see
what was happening and how phloem and
aadmi changed with height and so we
looked at a lot of the same things we
looked at the other ones so these are
those longitudinal sections looking at
the plates using scan Electrike Moss
microscopy to look more detail at the
plates we sampled trees and multiple
Heights and we found a very similar
pattern to what we saw in the morning
glory in terms of their Anatomy so we
found that this is the bottom of a tree
and the top of a tree the tubes were
bigger at the bottom they were often
more pores in the plates the pores and
the plates were bigger and so what this
is suggesting is that as trees are
getting taller the same as morning
glories are getting bigger the new
vascular tissue they're making is larger
and can move more and so they're
adjusting as they're growing and this is
is really important because it helps
prevent issues with growing tall it
would be very inefficient if you could
only grow a few meters before your
transport of carbon became slow right
yeah no that's a great question or
probably both so we're I'm not going to
talk about the work that we've done
within the same species but when they're
smaller they all
have smaller conduits but there is some
variation between species in how big the
conduits and that does seem to relate to
size so it could be that there's a
little bit of both in there but that's a
great question so here's here's what
some of the data looks like and I'm
gonna explain this to you because it's a
little bit counterintuitive if you
haven't looked at many crafts of scaling
relationships so this is resistance okay
so this makes sense higher resistance
would mean slower transport right and we
do this as distance from the top of the
tree so at the base of the tallest trees
the resistance is the lower lowest and
as you go towards the top of the trees
and as you move towards shorter trees
the resistance gets higher and it looks
like from what we can tell the
relationship within a plant within a
species is the same as a cross species
seems to be a pretty constant scaling
relationship that we see and how
resistance scales with height which is
which is really exciting but of course
the thing that it leaves us with is this
question of is it enough right the
Morning Glory had to do this and more
what are the trees doing more is then
anatomical changes we're seeing here
enough to allow for transport and really
tall trees so to get at this we also
went back to modeling because there are
some things that unfortunately we just
can't always measure but the modeling
gives us a nice framework for how to
think about what's going on and so these
are some basic models of the phloem
looking at how we would expect pressure
to change with different Anatomy so if
you had a situation where there was no
change in Anatomy along the length of a
tree as
you got taller you would need to have a
really high pressure okay
but if you put into the model this same
scaling relationship that we saw where
resistance actually just decreases
because the tubes get bigger and the
pores get bigger it drops off and you
don't ever need those really high
pressures and so we wanted to know
whether this was in the range of what
you could find in the leaf of a tree in
terms of the pressure is that reasonable
can a tree achieve that much pressure
and to do this oh I forgot there is this
I was gonna explain these two lines so
we did make some differences in our
assumptions about the cross sectional
area of the phloem it's a little bit
complicated to measure this in a tree
but it doesn't matter much for the
actual pattern we here but we decided to
try to measure pressure in leaves on
intact trees so we built a scaffolding
we used a bucket truck we brought a
microscope up to the canopy and use
these little peeko gauges this work was
done primarily by Yann and Michel
Knobloch to actually measure pressure in
leads in tall trees and what we found
was the oak that we studied had a
pressure that was close to a mega Pascal
which is completely within the range
that we would that would be would make
transport feasible with this Anatomy so
what this suggests is the changes that
we're seeing in the anatomy these
changes in trees in terms of the
resistance is enough to allow tall trees
to transport really long distances
without much pressure The Morning Glory
seems to have this added capability to
pressurize its phloem which is also
helping as it along gates and so where
we're having these really interesting
changes that are facilitating long
distance transport in
the phloem and so as I mentioned we're
also doing some work within species now
we're doing work on Oaks different sizes
to try to understand what happens as
plants develop and we also have a larger
data set of about 50 species that
include more vines and trees and herbs
to get another understanding on how
height impacts a whole variety of these
different organisms and what their
phloem looks like so stay tuned there
will be more coming on about this so the
last thing I want to leave you with is
some work that I'm more recently getting
into and this is just the beginning
phases of it but I have become really
interested in what happens seasonally in
plants and how they change and
specifically how the carbon transport
system change and so once again I've
gone back full circle instead of going
to fruit I'm gonna go to flowers but
thinking again about transport into a
specific organ as its developing and so
there's a sort of a battering of
research out there on what happens to
the phloem in the winter there's not a
lot of information on this there was
some great classic work done using a
fits to collect phloem samples and
looking at the concentration of sugars
that suggests in the winter
sugar concentrations get higher in the
SAP of the phloem so not necessarily
surprising it might be what you would
expect compared to what's happening in
the rest of the plant there's also been
a lot of anatomical work looking at
kalos deposition and sometimes this is
deposited and then dissolved in the
spring sometimes it appears that plants
just forsake their phloem from that year
and don't reuse it the next year but
regardless the way you look at it phloem
transport likely decreases in the winter
in most species either because of
viscosity or because of occlusion and
because they're just not moving as much
so to me this begs the question of well
what's happening in the spring
right and I got interested in this
because I have had a lifelong level
Boulos and I've done a lot of work on
them and I love the fact that they
flower so early in the spring and there
are a lot of plants both in our
horticultural and our natural landscape
that do this often the first growth we
see is flowers so this made me start
wondering about well what's happening in
the phloem of these species how are they
actually growing these new organs
sometimes when there's still snow in the
ground in the spring and so I've been
doing work on five just different gener
here I and what I've done is I have
pairs of species that flower really
early without their leaves so they
flower precociously
and ones that flower later with their
leaves but they're in the same genus so
I can try to separate out what's
happening in terms of the flowers and in
the leaves in development and so I'm
just going to show you a little bit of
the work they've been doing on this so
I've been trying to think about when and
how is carbon moving into this bud this
is where I started with just a simple
simple thought all right these all have
preformed flowers they make them the
year before in the summer but they're
not at full size so there's some certain
amount of carbon flux there's gonna
period of dormancy and then in the
spring they're gonna have more carbon
flux as they grow and I wanted to know
what's happening in terms of the timing
of this and how much carbon is is moving
in there and so the first thing I did is
I just looked at biomass and carbon
content of the tissues and this is some
of the data here so this is the floral
biomass but we're looking at the biomass
as a percentage of the total flower so
if you take a dormant bud and you say
how much does that weigh and what
percentage of the final weight of the
flower is that dormant but this gives
you an idea of how much does it actually
have to grow in the spring so the
dormant buds for exam of the Hema
malleus the witch-hazel are almost nine
percent of the final weight of the flour
they show very little growth in the
spring almost everything they need to
flour is there or they get dormant but
with the other species it's more
variable and the interesting thing that
came out when I just did this simple
look at these different pairs is that
there's a big difference based on when
you flour and in some ways maybe this
also seems intuitive but these plants
that are flowering really early are
investing much more of their carbon a
year prior to flowering then the ones
that flower later so the darker purple
here you can see they're all larger for
each species and I put some pictures
here of the dissected buds and these are
all at the same scale so this is a
precocious early flowering cornice this
is a non precocious same with a Magnolia
and the Salix this was consistent across
all of the groups that I've looked at
the ones that flower early always invest
more carbon in their buds
prior to dormancy prior to the winter
now that being said none of them besides
Tama MELAS is pretty borderline put all
their carbon in so they all need their
phloem in the spring or that's what all
the evidence suggests and I actually
tried to test this by looking at
girdling I girdled these branches remove
the phloem to see what happened and when
you girdle them they don't increase in
biomass so there's no growth in the
spring they might still bloom but
they're gonna be tiny and they're gonna
be the same weight as they were doing
dormancy so it seems like they need
active phloem in them and they actually
probably require the phloem for more
than just the carbon so I spent almost
this whole talk talking about carbon but
that carbon comes in an aqueous solution
it comes in water and when you're
talking about small structures that
don't use a lot of water the phloem can
actually be really important in
hydrating them and so I did some models
looking at how much water you need based
on the measurements I took of the bud
for those flowers to expand and for most
of the species there is enough water in
the phloem to hydrate those flowers
prior to blooming prior tan pieces all
right so it looks like the phloem could
be what's supporting these flowers
really early in the spring and I
actually did this model too I just want
to mention with different assumptions
about respiration because I didn't have
temporal measurements of respiration
during the entire span of floral
development and the if you if you assume
there was no respiration handful of
species came out as not having enough
water in their phloem to hydrate the
flowers but as soon as you put even a
low rate of respiration there was maybe
one there was one species left and if
you got a little bit higher there were
none so I would say that the phloem
should be at least able to supply 60% of
the water that these flowers need
possibly all of the water they need
during development so that's a great
question so with this work I've been
focusing on just up into an thesis when
they open the only one that I believe
has store mates is the Magnolia and I
have a graduate student actually right
now looking at floral loss through
through these different structures and
what happens after in theses because I
think after that after they open and
those petals are exposed the whole story
changes yep so so this as I say is just
an ongoing project but I mentioned
before how I have my favorite projects
the ones that leave two more questions
and this leaves the big question because
I just gave you some tidbits I said the
phloem seems active in the spring it's
supplying carbon and water but to me
this is really intriguing those plants
that flower early invest more of their
carbon the year before that tells me
there's there's probably some
restriction on phloem transport in the
spring so maybe they don't have a big
enough window to transport or maybe
they're transporting at a slower rate
and so this is something
we're currently looking in to try to
actually what's happening in terms of
transport into these flowers in the
spring but you know that will come at a
later time hopefully I'll have more
answers and more questions so so with
that just to wrap it up you know I hope
I gave you a little bit of a hint of
some of the cool questions that are out
there I in no way claimed to have
answered this question I think we are
just scratching the surface in terms of
the connection between the structure and
function in the phloem but we'll we
ended up with at the end of all this
it's a lot of really cool questions so
if there's anybody out here looking for
cool research projects on the phone
there's a lot of them out there so with
that I'd like to thank you for your
attention and I can take any questions
that you have is the same then they
either are completely for the more
leaves which just either branching horn
or so yeah so the one thing I know so
this is a little complicated because
most of the plants I was growing never
got to the size in a greenhouse you
can't grow them as big so I don't know
if you grew like a Hubbard squash under
the exact same conditions as a Atlantic
giant in the field weather would produce
more in the greenhouse they were
remarkably similar but they showed a big
difference in their pattern of
allocation to their fruit in terms of
how many fruits versus how big and so it
might be more of a trade-off at that
level I'm not sure but without actually
growing the Hubbard squash and pushing
them to the extent that those Atlantic
Giants are pushed I'm not sure that we
could see at that scale does that make
sense
yeah it could be and so the other thing
they do there's a lot of practices they
do during giant pumpkin growing and they
do a lot of very careful pruning and
maintenance and planning about the whole
plant and how it is put out and the
problem that that there is with these
field grown ones as they all use the one
variety so to convince somebody to put
that much effort into doing experiments
of a whole bunch of different ones is
really would be really hard but there's
a lot of thing I could definitely
believe that there's something going on
typical dominance or branch hanging for
sure it's a great point no it's a great
question and I wish I had an answer for
it but I don't so I I a while ago
participated in a study where we
actually compiled a lot of data from the
literature and we're trying to get an
idea of how variable sugar
concentrations are in the phloem and the
the problem that we have is there's a
lot of methods that people use for
measuring this and it's not clear how
equivalent they are and so there's a lot
of debate in general about whether like
a particular study that showed a really
low or really high concentration is
actually realistic she should always be
in the middle and so the default is
often in our models to do what the
average is where we see it it's also the
concentration that's that's sort of
optimal for transport in terms of
viscosity but I mean the work that I
showed you the Fisher showed that the
seasonal changes shows that it does
change it's likely not the same all the
time and we don't know we don't know how
much it differs between species and how
dynamic it is yeah do you have any
questions
this is generic I'm
wondering what other molecules you
measure with the transport whether it
was just carbon or whether you included
nutrients like potassium and easy 'm
other things are actively transported in
the phloem to see if there was any
correlation between the carbon that was
transported and and and these nutrients
and we also have RNA and all kinds of
other things that are moving so any
hints about that yeah yeah it's a great
question I have not I focused primarily
on carbon and sugars I know that it's a
really active and interesting area of
research as a lot of things that are
transported in the phloem that have huge
implications for how plants function so
yeah I think it's be a great thing to
look at more in the future
it so I've actually gotten different
opinions on this when I've talked to
people who do more of the modeling and
who study physics since long transport
generally the thought is that it doesn't
matter a lot because of you have to get
really tall to have it be a significant
impact and most plants with the
exception of some of these really tall
trees do not have those really long
different distances between a source and
a sink where you would be tall enough
that gravity would have a big impact
it's possible that in really tall trees
it has some impacts but it's not clear
to me how much of an impact
we have time for one more question if
there is one
yeah within the same cult or depending
on how the winter goes over yeah no it's
an interesting question I mean I I sort
of present this as it being black and
white and it's it's not even for some of
the species that I've used it depends on
it seems to depend on even just the
micro environment they're growing in in
addition to yearly variation how much
the flowers and leaves overlap and I
don't know exactly what's going on what
soived I all say about phloem but I've
actually done a lot of work on xylem too
and I've done a lot of work on xylem in
this system and it seems like what's
happening with leaves is more tightly
tied to what's happening in this eylem
and that the flowers are disconnected so
my guess is that the signaling is just
different and depending on the
conditions the flowers are more flexible
if the phloem is easier to reactivate
which is my suspicion xylem is usually
reactivated later a lot of species
especially in cold climates so it might
be that if they're able to separate
themselves so to speak from the xylem
I'd be relying on the phloem that
flowers are able to come out before
leaves but it would depend on the year
yeah it's a great question this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu